toute cette semaine Tv Tours valent de
Loire se met à l'heure irlandaise dans
moins de 4 mois maintenant les
meilleures équipes de rugby du globe
s'affronteront pour la Coupe du monde
qui se tiendra en France l'équipe
d'Irlande vous le savez a choisi tour
comme camp de base Florent Clavel s'est
rendu à Dublin berceau du rugby
irlandais pour une série de reportages
il nous présente le programme de cette
semaine
bonjour ou plutôt hello from Dublin vous
voyez derrière moi la Viva Stadium avec
ses 50 000 places c'est le deuxième plus
grand stade d'Irlande là il est vide
mais attention quand ça joue ça donne
une ambiance de feu celle par exemple du
match entre le Leinster la grande équipe
d'Irlande et son voisin du Monster
rencontre que je vous ferai vivre
extrait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce match est d'autres c'est pour les
supporteurs comme une grande répétition
avant la Coupe du monde de rugby qui se
tiendra en France en septembre et ils
auraient tort de se priver c'est fans
absolus leur équipe fait partie des
favoris c'est l'année où jamais pour le
15 de trèfle et d'ailleurs le manager
général de l'équipe ne s'en cache pas
Michael cornet qui veut ramener la coupe
à la maison
on respecte tout le monde et même si on
n'a jamais dépassé l'écart de finale en
Coupe du monde
encore une fois on est raisonnablement
confiant et on sera bien préparé
à coup sûr la venue de cette équipe
d'Irlande c'est aussi un énorme coup de
pub pour la Touraine qui en a bien
besoin les Irlandais ne savent pas trop
encore nous placer sur une carte vous le
verrez évidemment on leur en veux pas
comment peut-on transformer ces
supporters en futur touristes pour nous
répondre j'ai notamment rencontré
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur de France et oui
Vincent Guérand qui espère aussi
profiter de cet événement pour renforcer
les liens économiques et culturels avec
l'Irlande après le brexit il y a une
sport naturellement qui mettait plus
dans la dimension d'une extension
d'exploitation culturelle
[Musique]
il est formidable que la France
accueille cette année la Coupe du monde
de rugby que Paris accueille l'an
prochain les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques c'est une formidable
occasion de démontrer la capacité
d'accueil de la France la capacité
d'organiser des grands événements et de
mettre en valeur naturellement son
patrimoine sa culture je vous parlerai
aussi de la succès story d'un tourangeau
expatrié Dublin 20 ans maintenant que
Mathieu gorge s'est fait un nom dans la
tech et puis ne boudons pas notre
plaisir je vous proposerai un coup de
projecteur sur les 20 tours en jeu qui
séduisent de plus en plus nos amis
dublinois voilà pour le programme et
tout ça sous un grand soleil ce qui est
plutôt rare ici